do you know that Java the
object-oriented language follows right
ones Run Anywhere principle which makes
it highly portable and platform
independent Java code runs on any
platform with the help of java virtual
machine nowadays Java is used for
various applications including web
development mobile apps and enterprise
software this created a huge need of
java experts in the industry according
to Glassdoor the average annual salary
of a Java developer in United States is
dollar 94 000 if someone holds a senior
Java developer position their average
illness salary increases to 114 000 the
upper limit of the salary range reaches
280 000 annually hope this excites you
to explore more in the world of java if
you are looking to become a Java
developer then have a look at post
graduate program in full stack
development with this amazing program
you will be benefited with Caltech ctme
postgraduate certificate receive up to
25 CEUs from caltex ctme attend master
classes from caltex ctme instructors
live virtual classes led by industry
experts Hands-On projects and integrated
Labs by the end of this course you will
be skilled with agile Java hibernet and
jpa spring core 50 HTML5 and css3 AWS
JavaScript and there is a huge list on
the board expertise in tools like
angular css3 Docker git HTML5 Jenkins
mongodb MySQL will add value to your
resume so hurry up and enroll Now find
the complete course details from the
link in the description box millions of
Learners are benefited with our courses
listen to the success story in their own
words learning is growing and we not
only decided to grow together in life
but learn and succeed together as well I
successfully switched my career to full
stack Java domain with a 15 salary hike
and I was able to grab new opportunities
in my current organization and also
receive a 10 salary hike hey I am
swamijit Basu I am a senior QA engineer
at Encore Inc and I am show me and I
work as a senior quality Analyst at
doodle blue Innovation we started our
upscaling journey together which simply
learned and certainly we made the right
choice after our marriage I had to
relocate to Bangalore and take a year
Gap after working 45 years but I decided
to restart my career again and make a
switch to software domain so I enrolled
myself in full stack Java developer
program from Simply learn seeing my
wife's passion for learning every day
inspired me to take up a course on
simply learn as well I've always been
passionate about technology and learning
devops was always in my bucket list when
I saw simply learns collaboration with
Caltech ctme I decided to take a course
on PG devops after the course I not only
switched my career to post a Java
development with person and
increase salary but now also I can work
from home since it's a software domain
and being the new mom that's the best
thing one could ask for to spend time
with little one during these early years
for me learning devops was fun and
fulfilling at the same time earlier I
had to rely on others at work but after
upskilling myself I single-handedly can
set up the entire blueprint on my code
base alone and get the desired output
and because of that I could grab new
projects in my organization with a 10
percent salary high we enrolled to
upscale ourselves when we were
first child so upscaling Journey with
learn would be undoubtedly very special
to both of us while doing the course we
did come across a lot of challenges due
to the pregnancy but my wife showed me
was a great inspiration for me as she
was handling it all together and she
kept motivating and inspiring me all the
way moreover the recorded classes and
the weekend class helped us maintain the
balance between work and learning apart
from work we love to spend time with our
little one learning with simply Learned
was quite a fulfilling experience for
both of us we believe that growth
doesn't happen overnight rather it's a
journey of several small steps and
upskilling is one of them hello guys
this is vikesh and let's get started
with the first topic of this series
which is about introduction to Java so
when we talk about Java it is one of the
most popular programming language out
there and it was created way back in
1991 but it was publicly released only
in 1995. it was developed by one of the
famous developers of Our Generation who
is James Gosling at Sun Microsystems and
then later Java was acquired by Oracle
and today Oracle owns Java Java is very
simple and easy to use and we will look
at different aspects of how it is easy
and simple to use it's a write once Run
Anywhere type of programming language
again we will look at details into into
into this particular concept as well and
when we talk about the usage of java you
can use it to build web applications
mobile applications desktop applications
even command line application Asians and
at the same time you can also use it to
build complex applications like gaming
applications building microservices or
building distributed computing Etc let's
talk about the features of java so one
of the most prominent features of java
is that it's an object-oriented
programming language which means that
everything which happens in Java happens
around objects objects enable the
execution of the program objects talk to
each other to exchange data and messages
we will look about a look at the concept
of objects in details in the upcoming
lectures it's a platform independent
language which means that again going
back to the previous point of write once
Run Anywhere it basically enables the
program to be run on any platform once
compiled so once you have prepared your
program and you have compiled your
program then your compiled program can
be run on any platform it is a strong
type checking language which means that
it will force you to respect the
contracts of the variables to the data
types for example if you have created a
collection which should accept strings
then you can only insert strings in that
collection and it will not allow you to
add an a number or an integer into that
collection so it's a strongly typed
checking language so when you run your
program it's a two-step process in Java
you compile the program and then you it
then you execute the program which we
also call as interpretation so you have
a Java compiler and you have a Java
interpreter you first compile your
program and then you run the program
using the help of java interpreter Java
also provides automatic garbage
collection it's a really important
feature and if you talk about the
languages prior to Java like C or C plus
plus they did not offer this capability
and this capability made Java really
popular because it could automatically
find the unused objects and variables
and remove them from the memory to free
up memory space for the program
execution it also provides
multi-threading support which means that
you can build multi-threading
applications like a gaming application
if you take the example of a racing game
for example so there's they can be one
thread which is monitoring your
leaderboard score there can be another
thread which is displaying the speed of
the car there can be another thread
which is displaying the graphic there
can be another thread which is
displaying the sound so you see all of
these threads are working parallely and
Java provides the support to create such
applications using the multi-threading
capability it has Java is secure by
default because there are no pointers in
Java so there are no possibilities of
having any memory leaks or any reference
leaks from the application again if you
take the example of programming
languages like C or C plus plus you had
the concept of pointers and the we
witnessed lot of a lot of scenarios and
lot of incidents where there was a
memory leakage happening in the in the
production application which was which
was really a bad experience for the
organizations so Java removed the
concept of pointers totally from its
programming language it's also a very
robust language because it provides a
really great exception handling
framework out of the box which
developers can use and Implement to
build really resilient applications so
now let us understand how a Java program
is run so at first you basically write
your Java program and you store your
Java program into a DOT Java file then
you compile your Java file with the help
of the Java compiler once the program is
compiled the compiler is going to
generate another file which is a DOT
class file and this dot class file is
basically the compiled file or also
known as the byte code file so this byte
code or the dot class file code can be
run on any platform be it a Linux
platform or a Windows platform or a Mac
OS platform or any other platform to
give you some more context the first two
steps where you write your Java program
and you compile your Java program can be
run on any machine let's take an example
that you ran these two steps on a
Windows machine so you ran your you
write your program and you compile your
program on a Windows machine which
generated a DOT class file then you
transported this dot class file to a
Linux machine and it also worked there
you transported your dot class file to a
Mac OS machine and it worked there as
well and that's what brings the platform
Independence concept of java that you
can write the program once on any
platform and once you have the byte code
available then you can run this program
on any other platform of your choice
okay so that was about how the Java
program execution works and how the
platform Independence is actually
achieved now let us spend some time to
understand the anatomy of java so once
you download Java and install Java on
your local machine you will hear the
term jdk actually if you will see that
in the next lecture that when you try to
download the Java it will say jdk
download jdk stands for Java development
kit so the Java development kit is the
installation of the Java this is what
you're going to install on your machine
once the jdk or Java development kit has
been installed the jdk will provide lot
of other components as well like Java
runtime environment or JRE Java virtual
machine or jvm some class libraries and
some other supporting libraries so let
us understand what happens when your
program is run and how these components
work together to make sure that your
program runs as expected let's start
from here so you install jdk or the Java
development kit you write your program
and then you compile your program with
the help of java compiler which is
provided by jdk once the program is
compiled your dot class file will be
generated and then you can run
that.class file using GRE in fact if you
just run your program on your local
machine JRE will automatically kick in
and run your dot class file so the Java
runtime environment or GRE runs your dot
class file with the help of these three
components let's talk about first
component which is Java virtual machine
or jvm so the Java virtual machine is
actually the virtual environment inside
which your program runs this is the real
main environment inside your dot class
file is running so when when this
program is running how does it achieve
this environment for achieving this
virtual virtual machine environment it
would need some runtime libraries and
that is provided by these class
libraries for example there would be a
runtime jar or rt.jar as a shorthand
which will be supplied to the program at
the runtime to make sure that the
program runs smoothly then there are
other supporting libraries as well which
your program may be using for example if
this program this dot class file is
let's say a calculator program then it
might be using a square root function
from java.math package so how do how
does the java.net package gets supplied
at runtime it would be supplied by the
other supporting libraries which are
present inside GRE so GRE will make sure
that your program runs inside the Java
virtual machine it gets the required
runtime libraries and it also gets the
libraries which are referred in your
program at runtime and this all together
will make sure that your program is
running so you can see jdk basically
provides GRE automatically and jvm
automatically but you can also install
grg separately if you talk about that
use case where you compile your program
on a Windows machine using jdk and then
you exported your dot class file to
another machine and there you just
install the GRE you don't install jdk
there you just install the runtime
environment and you can run the dot
class file just using the runtime
environment and that brings us to the
end of this lecture let's get started
with installing Java we will basically
look at how we can install Java on a
Windows machine so the first step to
install Java is to download it from the
official Oracle website so for that
let's open a web browser and let's type
jdk Java download and hit enter then you
need to find the link which says
oracle.com because like we discussed in
the previous lecture uh Java is owned by
Oracle so we need to download it from
the official website only so we can
click on this link which says Java SE
downloads it will bring us to the
downloads page and we will see different
versions of java you can see the Java
sc15 you can see Java se14 you can also
see Java se11 and all the previous
versions another thing which you will
notice that it says LTS here which means
long term support basically long term
support are the releases for which
Oracle is going to provide long-term
security patches and updates for the
non-lts releases Java will not provide
long-term support and long-term patch
fixes and long-term security fixes so
it's a good idea to analyze and evaluate
on which version you want to develop
your applications on for this demo I
think it is fine we can go with the
non-lts version and even for your for
your customer facing applications you
can start with a non-lts version and
then upgrade to the latest LPS version
whenever that is available so for this
demo we can download Java se15 and you
can also do the same on your machine it
will work exactly the same way as an LTS
works so you can click on the jdk
download option here let's click on that
it is going to bring up the downloads
detail page and you can see there are
multiple options given here in terms of
what platform you want to install Java
on whether it is a Linux platform or it
is a Mac OS machine or it is a Windows
platform so like I said in the beginning
of the demo that today we are going to
see how we can install this on a Windows
machine so I'm going to download the
windows x64 installer here if you are
working on a Linux machine or a Mac OS
machine you can download those
respective installers as well so you can
see the exe here so let's click on this
once we click on this we'll get this
pop-up which will ask us to accept the
Oracle technology Network license
agreement so we can hit this checkbox
and click on download jdk 15
and this shall start the download and
you will see some some exe getting
downloaded in in your download box here
but as the download is going to take
some time and uh I'm not going to wait
for that and that's the reason I have
already downloaded the jdk 15 for this
particular demo and that jdk is is
sitting here on my desktop which I have
downloaded prior to this demo so we'll
just run this particular exe which is
exactly the same exe as the one which is
being downloaded so let us double click
on this it will ask you for this pop-up
in some cases so you can just hit yes
basically it is asking whether you trust
this exe or not but as we downloaded
this from official Oracle website then
we can trust this particular exe so I
will hit yes and now the installer is
going to unpack and you might get a
screen like this which will be an
installation wizard for the Java SC
development kit 15. another thing which
before I proceed I just wanted to
highlight that as well that you might
have noticed about jdk here it's exactly
the same term which we covered in the
last lecture that when you install Java
you basically install the jdk which is
the Java development kit and this is
also visible here when it says Java SC
development kit 15. so let's hit next
then on this particular page you have
the option to change the installation
location of java if you want to by
default it is going to install in C
program files slash Java slash jdk15 but
if you want to change the location and
you want to install Java to a particular
custom location of your choice that is
also possible you just hit change here
and then you can choose whatever
directory or folder or place you want to
install this Java on and you can
basically select the appropriate
location for this particular case I
don't want to change that I'm happy with
the default location which is available
here so I'm just going to proceed with
this particular location here so I will
just hit next and then Java is going to
install and it's it's very fast
installation It generally takes few
seconds as you will see in this demo
basically it is going to unpack all the
all the libraries and all the runtime
libraries and all the class path
libraries which we discussed in the
previous lecture and put all that into
the location which we specified to
install Java it will also set up the
rest of the prerequisites which are
required to run Java successfully so
looks like the Java has been
successfully installed as is visible in
this message and there's also a next
step if you want to access the tutorials
or the API documentations the developer
guides the release notes Etc I don't
want to do that so I will just hit close
here and now if we want to just verify
if Java is is installed or not then we
can verify that from the command and
prompt let me just exit this and let's
go to the command prompt to very verify
to see if Java has been successfully
installed so to do that we'll we'll just
open the search bar and we'll type CMD
it is going to show us this command
prompt here we'll click on this and it
will open the command prompt for you
like it has opened for me and there you
just need to type Java hyphen version
and you hit enter if you get a message
like this it means Java has been
successfully installed if you get a
message saying that Java is not
recognized as a command it means that
Java is still not successfully installed
and something has gone wrong in your
installation and in that case you might
want to restart you might want to go
back and reinstall this Java exe again
so in this case it looks like it has
been successfully installed and we can
also get some interesting information
from here we can see which version of
java has been installed it says Java
version 15. we can also see that the JRE
is also installed the Java SE runtime
environment or JRE is also installed and
and we can also see that the jvm is also
installed which is Java hotspot server
VM VM means the virtual machine so if I
connect this back to the previous
lecture we can see that the Java jdk
basically installed the JRE as well as
the jvm as well and the complete Java
package has been successfully installed
now we are ready to use Java a Java
program and run Java programs on this
machine and at this step I would like to
conclude this lecture in in the next
session we will be discussing how we can
install Eclipse because that would be
the natural next step for any Java
developer that they want to install Java
and then they want to install eclipse
and start working let's get started with
installing eclipse on a Windows machine
so the first thing which we need to do
is to download Eclipse so for that I'm
just going to open my web browser and
type Eclipse download press enter and
then you need to find the link which
says eclipse.org downloads which is the
first link in my search results you can
also see it says Eclipse downloads the
eclipse Foundation an eclipse Foundation
is the is the organization which
maintains the eclipse installers so we
can click on this once we click on this
we will be redirected onto the eclipse
downloads page and there again you will
see bunch of options you will see the
default option highlighted which would
be the eclipse in installer for for GRE
for Mac OS windows and Linux and then
you have some other tool platforms
option as well like Eclipse G or Orion
which you might want to use for advanced
cases but for running Java applications
all you need is an eclipse installer
which is coming from here so based on
your machine Eclipse will automatically
detect whether you want a 64-bit
installer or a 32-bit installer and you
can just click on this particular link
which says download 64-bit here so I'm
just going to hit download 64-bit it is
going to open this particular screen
where based on your current location
Eclipse will suggest the nearest
possible distribution mirror
distribution mirror is basically a
server which is present somewhere in
this world which contains this Eclipse
installer exe and Eclipse has created
these servers all across the Globes
these servers are basically called the
mirrors and based on your current
location which will be deducted taken
taken from your ISP from the internet IP
address from which you are accessing
this particular website so based on your
ISP location it is going to suggest you
the nearest possible mirror location so
that your download is the fastest so in
my case the nearest location is
Netherlands here as you can see and I
get a download option this is the file
name which says Eclipse installer GRE
windows 64.exe and if you think that
this mirror doesn't make sense just
click on this option select another
mirror and then you can choose another
mirror but generally it works really
well it works based on it works based on
your IP location and it's generally the
download speed is pretty good based on
the suggested mirror so I'm not going to
change the mirror location because I
think this works fine for me so and I'm
just going to click on this particular
button which is going to start the
download of the eclipse installer so now
I have I have hit the download button
and you can see see right now and exe
has been download has begun to download
uh it is going to again take some time
and uh I have already downloaded this
particular exe just to save us some time
and I'm going to use that exe to
Showcase how we can install it another
thing just wanted to highlight is that
eclipse is an open source organization
it works on donations so if you feel
generous about it and if you feel that
eclipse is doing really great work you
can also donate to it which will show
here so we can move to the next step
which is about installing so you can see
here I have an installer here an exe
file basically which I have
pre-downloaded to Showcase this demo I'm
just going to double click on this and
it is going to unpack the installer you
can see this this icon will be presented
to you which says Eclipse installer by
oomph oomph is basically the provider
for this particular installer who
manages the installer and based on your
computer's capacity and speed it is
going to take few seconds and I in the
background what it is doing is basically
it is unpacking this installer and
creating all the installation files
which it needs to successfully install
it on your computer once that is done
you will be presented with this kind of
screen and you will see that Eclipse
provides multiple different kind of Ides
for different set of developer
communities you will see an option which
says Eclipse IDE for Java developers you
will also see Eclipse IDE for Enterprise
Java developers you will see the IDE for
C plus plus and C developers web and
JavaScript PHP Eclipse committers who
basically contribute to the eclipse
organization or RCP rap tester
scientific Computing there are tons of
Ides which Eclipse maintains for our use
case throughout this series I think we
will be focusing on this particular IDE
which says Eclipse IDE for Enterprise
Java developers you can also use this
particular IDE but this is a very bare
bone IDE with very limited set of
integration like it says it includes a
Java IDE a git client an XML editor a
maven plugin and a Gradle plugin but if
you look at the Enterprise you will get
more Integrations you can use this
particular IDE to work on whatever you
work here so these all will work here
but in addition you can also use this
IDE to build a web application build a
web service build a jpa application data
tools Java server Pages faces Etc so
this is more a more advanced I would say
and we will go with this particular IDE
and you can also choose this ID if you
want to but for this demo we are going
to choose this one I will click on this
then it is going to show me which
virtual machine it is going to use so if
you remember in the previous lecture we
installed Java 15 it has automatically
detected that location by reading by C
program files folder and it has
automatically taken that if you have
multiple jdk installations on your
machine you can click on this icon and
change a different Java virtual machine
I am going to leave it as is again the
installation folder is also by default
taken to your C user's username slash
Eclipse slash the Jee version number and
again if you want to change this you can
also change a different installation
folder I'm going to leave everything as
default it will automatically create a
start menu entry and a desktop shortcut
and now I hit install it might come ask
you for a user agreement so you can hit
accept now and now it has begun the
installation the installation generally
takes a bit of time to complete in some
cases so again it depends upon your in
your in your computer's capacity and
speed basically if it's a good robust
machine with the with good capacity the
installation might be very fast as you
can see in my computer and if you have a
computer which is not very strong on
configurations you can just be patient
and wait for some time and the
installation will be finished once the
installation is finished you will see
this launch option here you will also
have an option to keep an installer if
you want to show the readme file but I
think the the main option here which we
are going to use is the launch option so
if you hit the launch option now